[Música]
qual é a transformação que a gente quer
ver de fato na educação das crianças e
adolescentes
o desenvolvimento humano é importante
que desde a infância a gente estimula o
melhor que existe em nós e desenvolva as
potencialidades de cada um connection e
colabore para que sejam desenvolvidas
iniciativas e soluções para o convívio
em sociedade
cada um tem uma maneira única de
enxergar o mundo maneira de pensar de
agir ea gente precisa estimular as
crianças e adolescentes para que elas
desenvolvam os seus potenciais máximos e
alcancem suas ideologias e maneira e
sonhos de ver o ted desenvolveu uma
metodologia inovadora de educação para
que qualquer educador em qualquer lugar
do mundo possa aplicar encontros com seu
grupo de alunos e eles possam
desenvolver as suas ideias que merecem
ser espalhadas é uma metodologia que o
pad utiliza com seus palestrantes ao
redor do mundo e que é uma referência
global e que agora tem a sua metodologia
para as salas de aula desde 2012 no site
do ted global tenha a as inscrições
abertas para os educadores se
inscreverem pra para a versão em inglês
e em 2018 esse ano há menos de seis
meses
a helena cresce organizador até que são
paulo recebeu a licença do ted para
aplicar essa metodologia em português
então educadores do brasil inteiro das
escolas públicas e privadas vão ter
acesso também esse programa inovador e
que já é referência no ted no mundo
inteiro
a proposta é no a nível mundial já com
já está presente em mais de 100 países
mais de 250 mil educadores ao redor do
mundo e milhões de estudantes que estão
sendo beneficiados com esse projeto
aqui no brasil em apenas seis meses de
implementação
a gente já tem mais de 100 educadores
inscritos em diversos municípios e mais
de 16 estados do brasil e do ano de 2019
a gente quer que esse projeto alcance
todos os cantos do brasil ea gente está
contando com toda a rede que já
participa do movimento do ted para
também se mobilizar e fazer parte desse
movimento de transformação de educação
no brasil e de forma orgânica está se
montando uma rede de educadores que
estão transformando a educação no país e
que estão levando tendências globais
para a sala de aula nos diversos
municípios do brasil então a gente
convida vocês também a trazer essa
iniciativa que promove nicípio de lavras
e transformar a educação de lavras da
região e do país inteiro
a gente tem um vídeo que não é
brasileiro ainda porque ele ainda está
no início do projeto aqui no brasil mas
é um vídeo da argentina que demonstra
bastante a a proposta do programa e dá
pra entender bem como que ele está
funcionando aí ao redor do mundo em 2014
passaria se seguirmos esse mesmo
processo e quatro meses continuam nas
ruas secundárias sabia absolutamente
transformado em 2010
[Música]
participam negro resto center com um
aluno de 7 morado até final do
secundário o que o principal é
acompanhada do professor é só o
facilitador e ficar colégio para que
helena arlant a iniciativa da professora
júlia de ser orientadores acompanhar
artigos guiar no novo horário
uma comunicação diferente da que sonham
em ter havido aumento da matéria e com
um projeto para games grande retorno
compartilhar suas idéias
ontem à portuguesa quer toque a multa aí
com um expectativa comunicar e hertha
que batia companheiro e imaginação é o
quadro é igual a todo momento são de
cada uma tinha que conectar se com seus
interesses e curiosidades ocupação sem
água caso e se oferece um espaço de
reflexão e de autoconhecimento está
pensado em quatro etapas na primeira
etapa a etapa de inspiração nos
primeiros encontros de lobos onde
consigo na segunda etapa etapa de
conselheiro na índia construímos média
na terceira etapa e também da
comunicação
transformamos receberam uma aula
e acordava com esse evento entrou
escolha uma recusa excelente para ser
algo diferente e sair generalidade
hannah deixando nos motivarmos outro
lado a lado com parte do chamado vamos
todos contestação mesmo caminho e
colégio pegando é só oradores de uma
classe c onde tanta gente como a dona de
fruta e está relacionado à onu entre 15
e 25 os matizes
o processo termina com uma tela é o mais
importante jogo passado e meio nas
escolas em cada um dos 5 entrou entre os
entes antigos quando os tipos de
públicos que não sabiam deixo esse
processo transformador ea crítica ao
final do seu amigo que começou na
comunicação com outra família racial e
incomodar nos permite ator encontrar
aqui aprendendo a tocar sanfona de multa
nieto temos de olhar para descobrir a
minha confiança em mim mesmo e quando é
que foi a melhor coisa que agora está
tão segura a adoção já que interessa
câmera filmadora funcionava no entanto a
lama governo encerrou a participação com
a polícia a prender um programa piloto a
andar com agentes é importante que os
animais separados há ninguém que podemos
ouvir uma carreira avança a reunião de
família achou muito pessoal
o último para faltar ao minuto 19 dentro
todos ali mas transformado tanto nos em
sigilo até nos típicos dos objectivos
propostos no forno seletivo também
aprendemos muito difícil jogar prendemos
uma maneira diferente do que procurar
não consente a encontrarem com lixo e
passeando por amor comunicamos uma
maneira diferente ficou finalmente é
esse é um programa que inclua participam
folha públicas e privadas em tributação
normal e desafios que temos para
inventar a educação do futuro da
educação que eu acerte mais produtivos
trecho aparecer pessoas que podem
realizar sem bloquear um desafio muito
grande
durante o ano a revolucionária prometeu
um grande jogo na arena e na direção
correta
e nessa direção na qual chico no solo
podem desfrutar de processos e no
caminho aprender com suas críticas para
subir à lusa
a idéia inicial é natural
animais caminhão e caminhão andré
marques a taxa sindical embora outubro
enquanto olha só de maconha
como o sr
foi o caso do piloto na loja de software
pela fifa
seu sonho é conhecer projetos em todas
as escolas do país
sei que são como 50 mil estamos ricos
estamos também pensamos conosco em 2011
80 em 2016 eo resto vai crescendo vamos
chegar a cobrir todo o país mutável
obrigada
[Aplausos]